egor you and I shall be the very heart  of a scientific enterprise that will  change the world we shall create a life  out of death it's alive do you realize  how significant this is all I have an  inkling I'm detective Inspector Turpin  I'm here to investigate missing body  parts not sure what you mean sir  well you're not afraid to challenge the  natural order mr. Frankish no and its  Frankenstein we shall create a man after  our own image questions um well you're  welcome  I think it is time you met our monster  Victor don't full charge  so life is well that's rather obvious  you have the chance to be part of what's  being electrocuted chased by monsters  and hunted by the police well if you're  going to concentrate on the dark side  be careful mr. Frankenstein  you toy with wrathful forces cannot  argue with that  mr. Habermann Lila optically like about  the DAF